all right
everyone hello
this is shelby smith head of user
onboarding
at link and today i'm going to be joined
by
steve and we are going to be discussing
the
uh the first 90 day challenge of 2021
and we hope you guys have set big
language learning goals for this year
i know steve has and we all have here at
the link team
and steve's going to join us in just a
few minutes and until then
um please interact with each other in
the chat
say where you're streaming in from and
we will get started in just a few
minutes
truck
so
alright
hi everyone drop a message in the chat
and say where in the world you are
streaming in from
i will start things off i am shelby and
i am
streaming from phoenix arizona
thank you guys so much for being here
we've got people from russia from brazil
from the dominican republic
from algeria italy
hi from america america is a big place
we've got ibrahim from egypt welcome
guys
so have you guys joined a 90 day
challenge
have you set some big language learning
goals for this year
share in a few words what your
language learning goals are what
languages are you guys learning
and what do you plan to do over the next
90 days and over the next year
tagalog will be coming
after the launch of link 5.0 it might
not come
with the launch but we do have several
languages lined up
um shortly after we launch
we've got people learning mandarin
french
my goal is to read for japaneses to read
800 000 words in 2021
i love that that's great that's a a goal
that
you will know when you have hit it so
it's
you know it's attainable
um i'm still learning french and
i i did fall off of my practice a little
bit
at the end of last year admittedly but
i've also been using
link to keep up on my spanish as well
it's great you know because you can save
your progress
individually in each of the languages
that you might study so
one thing i love to do is um
if i'm gonna read a certain article or
wikipedia page
i like to read it in spanish and i'll
import it into link so that it's really
easy to look up any word that i
don't know
so steve um informed me that he was just
running a few minutes late
but he will be here in just a minute so
i'm i'm reading your guys's
messages and i will i'll take some time
to
try to answer your questions um someone
asked how i got this
opportunity to work for link um
great question i was using link as a
user
um and then i
i just i loved the company so much that
i reached out
there was a job opening listed on the
site and
i reached out and said hey i really want
to work with you guys and
i i got a couple interviews and i guess
they liked me too
i've got a message here from steve so
i'm gonna let you guys keep chatting
and i'm gonna help him get in
yes i understand
people like to say link is too expensive
um
we will get to that at that point today
um so you guys you're gonna be able to
ask a lot of questions today of steve
i'm letting him in right now and uh we
will make sure we get to all of your
guys's questions thank you
steve welcome looks like you're on mute
okay there we go hi steve how are you
all right good thank you how are you i'm
good thanks
we're happy you can make it well i
apologize you know
first of all i was running a few minutes
late and then i find
every time i get on zoom it's a new
experience sometimes i manage to get in
sometimes not then you need some kind of
uh
passcode and then i go looking for that
and i can't find it
then i manage to log on with facebook
and then there's nobody at the meeting
and i contact you and you send me
another link and anyway
i probably sent you to the wrong place
i'm so sorry steve it's not a problem
i'm just in the chat with our lovelies
we're having a good time okay
good um so steve um yeah
we started because we
um we joined a 90 day challenge we want
to set
our language goals off strong for the
start of 2021.
um i know that you joined another
challenge
and you're still working on arabic
not quite so i did my 90-day challenge
on arabic
which i completed at the end of uh
november
and then we had a live stream in arabic
with my tutor mohammed
in cairo and we had a number of people
participate
including a professor from indiana or
somewhere
who teaches arabic so that was kind of
fun that was the that was it
so but i'm continuing to do some arabic
uh i download the mp3 files from
youtube and i get them transcribed
and um and then i study those maybe an
hour
or so a week to the extent that i can
steal time away from
persian which is right now my focus so
just a step back you know my goal is to
learn
three languages from the middle east
arabic persian and turkish
and the reason is because it gives you a
real sense of that part of the world
because the turks the arabs and the
persians have been intermingling and
fighting and sharing the same religion
and
influencing each other's culture and the
architecture and food and so that's a
whole big
part of everything from almost central
asia
to egypt to morocco that's a vast area
of the world
and those three languages are key but i
decided to focus in on arabic and
persian
because they both use the arabic script
and i find that in language learning i
like to read
reading is a big part i mean mostly i
listen because it's easy
i can do it you know whenever i want
during the day
but when i really sit down to study i
read and the biggest
obstacle for me is the arabic script
because
any new script it's not a matter of just
learning a script
this letter has you know represents this
sound
it's a matter of of your brain has to
get used to it
and it takes massive again massive input
so if i stay focused on arabic and
persian every time i'm reading
i'm just getting a little more used to
the arabic script
even though the letters have slightly
occasionally slightly different values
in persian and arabic by and large it's
it's the same a few extra
you know letters and the persian script
and stuff but it's overwhelmingly the
same so
that's what i'm doing so now i'm focused
on persian i haven't formally
you know established a 90-day challenge
but i'm happy to talk about what i did
during my arabic 90-day challenge
in order to stay on task because that's
ultimately why we go to these
challenges like we can all be studying
like right now i'm studying persian and
if i get some persian in during the days
that's fine and if i don't that's okay
too i'm not under the gun
right but with a 90-day challenge your
talent's a challenge you're challenging
yourself so that's
it'll be interesting for me to hear
other people's comments but
um i just said to myself i've got to
have
you know so many new you know links
created every week in other words i had
my goals right there in my
statistics so i've got it so that means
i have to get new content so
i have these new podcasts you know every
time i'm reviewing old material which is
good to do
i'm not creating new links so i have
enough i said i have an obligation to
create so many new links
so therefore i have an obligation every
day to
attach so much new material with which
is difficult
but i also wanted to increase my known
words total
so my known words total i'm going to get
them by
mining my saved links because any new
word
that i look up doesn't become known it
won't be known for a while
there's a delayed reaction there right
it's got to be
i've got to see it again and again and
maybe i review it
and eventually i i feel i can move it to
know
so in order to get my known words and i
had a target of reaching 20
000 known words in arabic so what i
ended up doing
obviously as i'm going through old
lessons because that's how you
you know i've got lessons with lots of
yellow saved links in them
it's a little more boring to read
something that you've read before
although you've forgotten a lot of it
and you've forgotten a lot of the yellow
links and what they mean their status
too and they remain status too even
though you see them three four five
times they're still status too you can
never quite
but what i try to do is i try to move as
many as i can to status three
and then i go into the vocab section and
of course i can select
you know sort four status three only
then i go through those lists and
i find that if i've been good about
moving stuff to status 3
or even moving new known words back to
status 3
where i once thought i knew them and now
i don't know them
so i collect in status three words that
i want to review
words that i think i might know thing
you know words and phrases that are on
the cusp
there's a for english learners there's a
phrase on the cusp okay
on the verge of learning and now i go
through there and i'll typically
and i i think my goal was to have a
hundred
you know increase my known words total
by 100 a day
so i have to go i have to go and and
mine my status three lists
and there's lots of them i got like 50
000 saved links in arabic so there's no
shortage of
total links but i i kind of refine it
down to maybe there's a thousand status
three words
so every day i've got to find a hundred
that i can move to know
but at the same time in my regular
reading i'm moving them from
one to two from two to three and
of course to create more links and also
i've got
to you know kind of create more links i
got to go to the new material
with unknown words with bluebirds so i
have these sort of mechanical
targets above and beyond my interest in
these podcasts about
politics in the middle east and stuff i
had these specific mechanical targets
to keep me going every day sort of like
uh
you know the stick and the carrot so if
the interest in the
podcast was the carrot these mechanical
targets were the stick
hitting me over the head that's another
great
english uh phrase right
hey steve do you happen to have any
earbuds
we're hearing that there's feedback on
my voice in your screen
okay
[Music]
anybody to get here i didn't let me just
make sure these are hooked up
i'm hearing you can you hear me
yeah i'm in the earbuds now okay is that
better okay
yes i think it is thanks so much so then
in that case you you i hope i'm hearing
it yeah i think yeah
okay bit of a delay um so in that case
you you completed your 90-day challenge
in
arabic and you had the goal to um learn
20 000 words or to read 20 000 words
no so good question because we have our
goals and i think
that those goals are are useful they're
sort of like
to keep us going that's what they're
there for the statistics they're not for
bragging
i know so many words right it's more
very concrete targets that you can go
after so my goal was
i had let's say 18 i don't remember but
i'm going from memory
i had 18 000 known words in arabic
again the way we count them at link
so different forms of the same word
count as
different words so there's some people
say well you can't do that because
they're really the same word it doesn't
matter
because you have to learn and sometimes
it's as you know in spanish it's easier
to learn
certain forms of a verb than other
forms of the same verb it might be easy
to learn the present tense
you know first person present tense but
it might be difficult
to remember every time the third person
in the past tense
so so treating these as different words
is to my mind perfectly legitimate
so i had 18 000 known words so i needed
to increase that by 2
000 right to get the 20 000 known words
that was one goal i wanted to reach 20
000 known words
it has been my experience that to really
be comfortable
understanding say podcasts and stuff
like that
you need a lot of words so
probably i would need 40 000 words to be
totally comfortable just pick up any old
podcast off al jazeera i
understand it all i probably need twice
as many
but i was hoping that if i could just
get the 20
000 words because in order to increase
my known words
total by twenty thousand you know i'd be
doing a lot of listening
and re-reading so constantly increasing
my familiarity with
the language so i figured i was hoping
that i'd be able to understand more of
these podcasts
without reading them that turned out not
to be the case i mean
but what i did discover is that uh what
i ended up doing now is
i don't know how much detail you want me
to go into here we
i think they i think they love to hear
the details so
okay please proceed so what i found so i
i still can't take a 25-minute
al jazeera podcast listen to it and
understand i get snippets i have a sense
of what they're talking about
but there's so much stuff that i don't
understand
so because i now i take my
mp3 file from al jazeera
and i put it on happyscribe which is the
automatic transcription service
and there you have an option to have
them produce the text
with timestamps what that
then allows me to do is i can use in the
import
into link there's a thing called an
import e-book and unfortunately that's
not obvious to people we have to change
that in the new system so people
understand
the advantage of that because what it
does is it preserves the timestamps
so with that import ebook
i drag and drop the
text which has been transcribed this is
the kind of the world we're living in
right
it's been transcribed on auto transcribe
i take
the text i drop it into import ebook
i now bring it in as a lesson with the
timestamps
preserved what that enables me to do is
each sentence i can't say it's a
sentence because
again going into detail because this
isn't automatically transcribed
the punctuation isn't necessarily there
so sometimes it's a short sentence
sometimes it's a paragraph of six seven
or eight nine lines
but if i tap on the audio symbol
which normally would play the text to
speech
it now plays the true audio
because text to speech you can't listen
to i mean i can't listen to it for more
than
you know 10 seconds but the natural
audio i hear it
it's the natural audio for this portion
of text
and so what i found i was doing more and
more is i would play the audio
and i would read the text in english
because we have the translation i mean
right so we get the translation
google translate which is quite good
it's not perfect but it's good enough
so i read that google translate in
english while i'm listening to the text
in arabic
now i understand more of what they're
saying then i go through the text
saving blue words looking up the yellow
words again
i fight my way through that text maybe
moving the odd yellow word
to known or from two to three so the
process is
you know do it in sentence mode listen
while reading in english
then go back in there and mine the text
m-i-n-e in other words like mine and i'm
mining it for blue words that i can
convert to yellow
for yellow words that i can move up in
status and so then i do that sentence
then i move on to the next sentence
on that basis i understand everything i
even understand it
while i hear it so i ended up doing that
and so all of that so the goal was to
understand more and more of these
podcasts and i did
achieve that so those were my goals
great
well i think it's it's really important
for all of our
viewers to really take that to heart
that even
even you steve at the level that you're
at in
your language learning journey um and
everyone looks up to you as
as the master um even you sometimes
you know fall short of the specific goal
you set
but that doesn't mean that you failed
you know you still made
you know substantial progress over the
last
year and in particular over the last
quarter of
2020 in your arabic and so
a lot of our users i think they they get
really like stuck in the strategy and
they
they want to emulate your style because
they see all the success that you've had
and it's so important that you guys are
hearing that steve you know he has
different kinds of styles that he'll
experiment with but
the most important thing is that he's
actually doing it
every single day and it's important to
not get paralyzed trying to analyze
what the best strategy is you know just
just finding something that
interests you that makes you want to
come back to learning the language every
day and as you guys can see
steve focuses a lot on reading i mean
that's the core thing and of course
he he tries to develop that
comprehension as well by
you are saying you are listening in in
arabic but
um reading in english at first right to
make sure that you were understanding
and and and i should say that that that
is a strategy that i tried before
because it's something you'll find on
the internet different people who do
that
and i can remember with uh check i had
bought an audio book
the good soldier shake a very famous
czech story
and i had the text because it's an old
book it's not a copyright i imported it
into link
but and then i also bought the book and
so listening to the audiobook while
reading
but that's not good enough because if
you're doing it say
lots of text like the whole lesson
listening to it in the target language
reading in your own language you
understand more if you read
along in english while you're listening
but there's so many words there that you
don't know
and you can't go back and find them
that's why this
strategy works much better in sentence
mode
because then you're listening to a chunk
of text you're reading it in english so
that
immediately increases your comprehension
but then you can go back
and go after those words and phrases
that you heard that you
knew you didn't know so i think this is
a strategy that i've attempted in the
past
but it has never succeeded whereas now
with sentence mode
it really works i should also say one
thing too
our progress in a language we're never
aware of our progress
but i notice now if i see like i um
you know follow certain people on
twitter in arabic and
persian and before if i if i saw a tweet
from someone in arabic and persian
all i could do is hit the please
translate like i couldn't read it
i couldn't read it it's just too
difficult even though i know some of the
words it's just
or you have a you know you have an
obstacle a psychological block or
you just feel it's too tough or the font
is too small or whatever
and now i can read them
so so that it's it's a and it's it's you
almost don't notice yourself progressing
so
i really would encourage people not to
be
frustrated at falling short of their
goals
ever i know every time i read in persian
and
and arabic i'm improving in my ability
to read that script
every time every time i'm listening i'm
getting a little better
i'm certainly not getting worse not that
it's a straight line
you might you know depending on the
context depending on the number of
things you might understand better
this time than you do the next time or
you might speak better one time and not
as well the next time
so it's not a straight line but we are
constantly improving so you just got to
stay with it
exactly thanks for saying that i i
always tell our users that
language learning is not a linear path
and that's why
link is the way it is that there's not
necessarily you know a lesson one and
then the lesson two
and so on we'll certainly we certainly
have recommendations for places to start
but um the most important thing is that
you're engaged with the content every
single day
and if you consider how you learned your
first language
you you were just in it every single day
and you were involved in it and you were
hearing it and
eventually you started reading it too
but there was
you know i i had a friend who told me a
mom and she said
you don't teach a kid a language they
just learn it
and so that's how you have to absolutely
get into link you know and it can feel
uncomfortable for people who are more
used to
you know being taught something and from
point a to point b to point c
um so just make sure you guys are in it
every day
and i'm sorry were you gonna add
something else i mean that's certainly
true
and uh you know it's not obvious if you
pick up a book
say that i have this i like buying books
so persian you know
introductory and then intermediate the
introductory is not necessarily easier
than the intermediate
i mean you're still dealing with words
most of the words are the high frequency
uh words so it's not like there is in a
language lesson one two three four five
it's just
the language so and and very often in a
lot of these books they'll
they'll begin by introducing the colors
and the names of your maternal uncle and
your
your uh paternal uncle and third cousin
and all these sort of
many different languages have special
words for different you know
relationships
and that's all lost on you it's very
difficult it's not something you're
familiar with
so that uh i think many stories is just
as good a place to start as any
it's just a guy gets up and goes has his
coffee and goes to work i mean those are
things we're familiar with so you can
start anywhere in a language and nor is
it obvious that the present
tense is easier than the past tense
right
exactly so we have so many great
questions from
our viewers so we're going to get into
those but just before that i want to
make sure that we identified
and you know what have you set some
specific language learning goals for
yourself for this entire year um or are
you just focusing on the next
90 days for now okay so i have to admit
that the 90-day challenge was i felt the
pressure
to force myself every day to do those
things to
convert a number of words to known to
save new words etc so i wasn't
anxious to get back into that right now
i'm doing what i want
so you know i'm studying persian i have
i have sahara in iran who sends me
phenomenal stuff like she's sending me a
series on
persian cooking and different types of
kebab and different types of
breads and then she does a series on
on the history and so i'm just enjoying
it and uh
as i do that i'm learning so i'm not i
but
lo you sort of in a more general sense i
want to continue with arabic version
and perhaps in the summer go back to
turkish turkish is
quite different from the other two like
all three are from different language
families
and probably persian if it weren't for
the script would be the easiest because
it's an indo-european language
uh arabic is the most difficult because
it's very different and it has the
arabic script
and turkish is actually i you know in
the little bit that i did
it doesn't strike me as that difficult
and it's written in the latin alphabet
and so that's why i put it on the back
burner but
i'm interested i'm interested in turkish
food my wife watches turkish
series on netflix i would love to be
able to sit down there and watch some of
them and understand them so
probably in the summer i'll introduce a
little more turkish in my diet
my middle eastern diet persian turkish
in arabic
i love that um i i know the the 90 day
challenge is incredibly demanding
um so um i i do encourage users if you
if you want to get you know a jump start
into your language learning goals for
this year
i do recommend it because it's a great
way to hold yourself accountable
and you know push yourself and hopefully
have a little bit of fun
in the process too but exactly and i
think therefore we should take it
seriously
and as you say once you've done that 90
days now you've pushed yourself to a new
level
so now you even if you now coast a
little bit you're coasting at a
different level
different level in terms of where you
are in the language but also a different
level in terms of your discipline
in learning so he even without the
pressure of the 90-day challenge i find
myself doing
more now having done a 90-day challenge
than i did before
so for all of those reasons take the
90-day challenge
seriously and i think it pushes you up
to a new level
in many ways absolutely so i i highly
encourage you guys to go on to link it's
in
the community section um and join a
90-day challenge
uh stick to it and then yeah then i mean
you're gonna
you're gonna reach levels that you
didn't really think were possible
in just 90 days and then um
and then pursue something that is really
interesting to you
um for those of you who didn't see our
french series last year um i got really
interested in
belgian hip-hop and that's something
that i've been
um following and studying in
in french and i was just telling these
guys in the beginning um you know to
keep up on my spanish
anytime i read an article or wikipedia
page i try to
find it in spanish and import it into
link so that it's really easy to look up
words
that i don't know so those are some
things i'm doing to stay interested
but now we're going to jump into the
questions we have a lot of them here
which one should we start with um
now steve you kind of spoke to this a
little bit but
you're more talking about just listening
to podcasts and audios
so i don't know if you ever watch shows
or movies in other languages anymore
um but what would you recommend um
would you recommend having english
subtitles on
um or would you have subtitles on in
your target language when watching
a show or a movie it depends entirely on
your level
i think if you watch um a series with
english subtitles more than anything
that's to
stimulate you encourage you get you
excited about learning the language
it i don't think it does a lot for you
in other words
the intensity of the language experience
is not that great
because you tend to read in english so
you hear the odd word in the background
that you identify but
by and large you're not in the language
environment so i would call that a
low-intensity learning environment but
one that
i mean i can remember some of the first
russian movies that i
watched when i was learning russian and
they struck me as very exotic
and stuff the one that took place in the
19th century in russia
it just got me very excited about
learning russia
but it didn't help me learn the language
so as you progress in the language
when you are able to follow along with
the
subtitles in the language that's much
much better
because now you're in the language both
in terms of what you hear
and what you read problem is most of us
when we are
you know at that stage where we're like
at a stage we're still learning the
language
we can't read fast enough to keep up
you know we sometimes don't realize just
how quickly we read in our
own language and how slowly we read in
the languages we're learning
like if you know when i when i go
through this arabic thing and i
i look at the google translate like one
look at a
three-line sentence i got the whole
meaning
whereas when i go to read in arabic i'm
reading word letter by letter word for
word
so it's very difficult if you're
learning a language to to read the
subtitles in the target language until
you're
really quite good and and when you're
really quite good
then it works because you can read them
fairly quickly and you don't necessarily
need to read them all because you're
understanding a lot from what you hear
so that's where i think that uh
i mean i i find that it's very useful to
import either from youtube or from
netflix
the dialogue into link
and then go through there and and pick
out
those words and phrases that you need
uh because as with everything you know
if you can even get a few more words it
makes the rest of it
more comprehensible so you know what i
mean as you move from
if it's thirty percent unknown if you're
moving down to 10 15
you're just picking up so much more so
that would be my strategy i would say
at an early stage you want to you're
studying whatever might be french
you get a hold of a french movie with
english subtitles uh it shows you paris
or it shows you the quote
or shows you quebec or whatever it shows
you and you get all excited and you want
to learn the language that's what it's
for
it's not a learning experience and you
want to get yourself to a point where
you can actually watch those movies
with the subtitles in the target
language
exactly that's like the full immersion
yeah
thanks steve um
an interesting question that just popped
up and don't worry guys we'll get to
some of the older ones too
um how can you make the most of a trip
abroad from a language
perspective and how does what we study
at home
impact our trips abroad
well having had the experience of
traveling to a country where i was able
to put in a few weeks
of learning you know a few phrases
it didn't help me a lot in other words
you really have to be prepared
so you know if you're going to if you
have the time
and you have a date six months in the
future
or a year ahead where you're going to be
visiting that country
that should be a tremendous incentive to
do as much listening and reading as
possible
and and as you get closer to your trip
maybe once or twice a week talking with
someone online
a tutor or whatever it might be in other
words i very much
recommend preparation before you get
there
because you can't just walk up to people
and stumble at them
in in their language they are not your
teachers
uh they may be nice to you but they all
have things to do
if you go into a store and you start
mumbling in their language
they'll humor you but then like what do
you want especially if they speak
english
especially for english speakers because
in many many countries the locals
actually speak english
and they have things to do so if you
expect them to respond to you in the
language you're learning you better be
ready in other words you've got to
understand what they're saying
you've got to be able to say what you
want to say and you can prepare for
all of that ahead of time and i've had
this experience i've had it with czech
even with arabic when i was in morocco
and if you can at least
halfway maintain a conversation i found
the taxi drivers
you know this lady that's running this
busy restaurant she was quite happy to
humor me in
standard arabic although in morocco they
don't speak standard arabic amongst
themselves you'll find
a lot of people willing to humor you if
you can at least maintain a conversation
and and then you activate all of your
passive
you know listening and reading starts to
activate pretty quickly
so you got to be able to hit the ground
running don't go there expecting that
just by being there for two weeks all of
a sudden you're going to be
you know you know improve your ability
i mean it's same like spanish if you go
to mexico i i'm not a
i haven't been there very often but a
lot of people do speak english
if you want to interact with people in
spanish you better be
up to the task so put a lot of effort
into it ahead of time
thanks steve i think that's great advice
um
someone also just asked um recently some
they cited something from your book the
linguist um that you recommend one does
more
writing to improve in the language how
often do you think we should write every
week
i know that you don't really talk about
writing very much and i don't know if
you still
write see in your target language there
is no question in my mind that writing
is good for you
writing is kind of like getting into
output uh with training wheels on
because as you're writing you can look
things up you can look up the correct
uh you know form of the verb you can
look up the conjugation
if it's say spanish you can look up
whatever you want you can look up words
so you can and you have the time to
think so
none of this works when you're speaking
right you gotta
speak on the fly you have to come up
with the word you have to come up with a
correct term and so forth the trouble is
you know right now i'm so when i learned
chinese obviously i
had to write and i think handwriting the
characters helped me a lot
and writing helped me learn the language
and help me to speak more and uh
french obviously i was a student in
france for three years in japan i
basically never wrote because and so
since then i haven't written because i'm
lazy i think it's good for me but
in japan i had the advantage that i was
surrounded by japanese speakers
so you know i could go to the store and
buy uh
some bananas or something like there is
no lack of opportunity to
to use the language and and many of the
languages that i've learned you know
they have different writing systems so
it's very hard to remember
the characters and hiragana and how to
write in arabic and how to write in
russian and stuff for greek
it's just too much for me i i derive my
enjoyment i do what i like to do i enjoy
the reading and the listing and
discovering more about the country
and stuff there's no question when you
write you slow yourself down
you're learning fewer new words you may
be learning them
better but you're learning them more
slowly so
it's all a matter of what you choose to
do one other bit of advice
something that i do mention in my book
you know there
in most languages the written form is
somewhat more formal than the spoken
form
in some languages like japanese there's
a tremendous tremendous sort of
difference in level depending on your
relationship to the person you're
speaking
to and their status and your status and
all this kind of stuff
i find as a learner your best to have
a neutral form of the language i have
always avoided
slang i've always avoided you know
trying to be too clever in my written
form
i write the way i speak i speak a
neutral form of the language
i write a neutral form of the language
it works in all those different
areas and if you write the way you speak
then your writing is going to help you
in speaking your speaking is going to
help you in writing
it's all the same language
and what uh like if you were
writing would you write pen and paper or
would you write on the computer
and what would you actually write okay
uh when i was learning chinese i had to
write by hand we had to learn
the characters i mean i
today i would to the extent that i have
written in greek or arabic
or or today when i go to write something
in any language
i use the computer i have uh and in fact
in russian
there is a phonetic keyboard so i don't
even have to know the russian
keyboard i just type it as in english
there's a few
different characters but i do whatever
is easy for me
that's my situation now if i were
learning the language if i were
dedicated to learning a language
i think i would use the keyboard because
it's so much easier
so i would get in arabic if it's arabic
and get up the arabic keyboard
or the korean keyboard and i just start
running away
and i probably if i were keen on russian
i would learn the russian
keyboard right now i'm not focused on
russian but if i were that was my goal
to learn this language i would
learn their keyboard and i would write
but using the computer because it's so
much easier
and we don't have that many
opportunities how many people write
handwritten letters to each other
handwritten notes to each other we don't
do that much anymore
so right yeah i would i would use the
keyboard sorry
no actually i don't even use the
keyboard i use dictation now
i cheat oh that's not really writing is
it
no it isn't but that's what i do but but
that's not teaching me the language
yeah but i must admit that in all of my
languages i have like 10 different
uh you know language keyboards on my
ipad or on my computer
and i just dictate and it works for me
it works in korean and works in greek it
works at russian works in chinese
japanese it works in all of them i go
back in and i correct
any errors but by and large i just
dictate right that way i don't have to
fuss with accents i can't remember in
spanish which accents and stuff like
that i just dictate and it comes out
more or less correctly yeah and then
you're practicing speaking
that's something that's right um
so a question we have here is uh do you
think
in english or do you think in the
language you're speaking
now of course this is if you're speaking
in a non-english language
well that's right so you know it depends
on the language
i think there is a sort of a continuing
continuum
so any language that you speak very well
like your own language
obviously you think in that language so
i think in french i think in japanese i
think in chinese
i think in spanish swedish
when i get beyond that the amount of
time i think in english
increases because the less capable you
are in that language
the less you're relying on natural
language
you know habits and reflexes that you've
developed through this
massive listening read so my russian i
would think i'm still
over half 60 70 percent i'm
i'm reacting in russian i'm thinking in
russian
uh and even in arabic and persian most
recent languages
30 maybe i am using natural reflexes
that i've developed in the language
because a lot of the structures are
different from english so you
you would sound very silly if you tried
to translate word for word from english
so i have some uh phrases that
that have become that i'm able to use
and then i fill in with things that i
translate
from english and i think the goal is to
get to where you're
70 80 90 thinking in the target language
great i certainly know and
my you know very limited experience that
it becomes so much
easier when you do start thinking in
your target language of course because
then you're not
translating inside your head and that of
course is going to slow you down
and we have a similar you know related
question um
from one of our viewers saying you know
how how can you get yourself to
be prepared so that you don't freeze um
when you hear
your target language and of course
i think that's a variable you know are
you trying to translate inside your head
um and i also think you spoke to this a
little bit before you know you have to
be well prepared
and reading and listening to a podcast
and doing flashcards is not at all the
same as speaking with a native
especially in their own country um or
speaking with multiple natives right
it's a it's a very different
experience so you have to be prepared
for
for not being perfect in the beginning
right i mean how would you
absolutely absolutely and that's why i
think it's so important to focus on
comprehension
but no matter how much you focus on
comprehension
to some extent you have to have had the
experience before
in order to be able to cope so that's
important to realize
i remember i was in the train station in
st
petersburg russia and i went to buy a
train ticket
and i i know i mean i understood russian
quite well i knew what i wanted to say
i asked her for a ticket to uh v-borg i
was going from saint petersburg to
vieburg
and she came at me i had no clue what
she was saying
because i hadn't been in that situation
before so you
have to be able to almost anticipate
what people are going to say
even if you know the words so so that
the fact that you stumble
it's normal and you're going to stumble
two or three times
and then you'll be familiar with that
situation that environment you can start
to anticipate what people are going to
say
and you'll be able to do better but you
have to be prepared to
not be prepared so to speak you know
that's
the nature of the game yeah i think that
a big
um a a really important principle with
language learning is you know
being okay with with not knowing
everything and with looking stupid
um or feeling stupid you know because we
were taught in school that you have to
have the right answer
and that sort of trains us to uh not
want to speak or not not want to dive in
if we're not 100 sure of ourselves but
that's no way to learn actually so you
guys have to be okay with
with not understanding every single
thing and with
not being perfect when when you speak
and just know
that you know people are always going to
appreciate you
trying and that's better and that's
going to get you closer to your goal
than
just sitting and waiting until you're
perfect because you're never going to
get there if you don't actually get out
there
and practice absolutely and
go with your first instincts like very
often we think this is
correct but like is it really correct
and then we hang back don't
just say it if it's wrong they'll go uh
you'll try something else
but but don't try to hang back trust
your instinct
if you have trained your brain through
lots of listening and reading
very likely your first instinct the word
that you want to use the expression that
you want to use is probably correct
and if it isn't there's no harm down
exactly
yeah because you'll you'll learn through
that experience right it'll either not
sound right or someone will correct you
or you'll learn it later on
yeah i mean a link of course as you guys
should know by now but maybe
i see some of you guys maybe are less
familiar with link it's it's really
a more immersive learning experience you
know you have to get out there and
expose yourself to the language
and um you are learning even though
you don't feel like you're understanding
every single thing and one of steve's
top you know keys to success is learning
to notice
don't a lot of you guys have questions
about memories like how many words do
you have to memorize
um you have very like analytical
questions about you know how many words
you need to know
and um i really encourage you guys to
go on our getting started guide and and
watch steve's seven um
you know secrets to success because one
of them really helped me which is
noticing over memorization
right absolutely and
and so you can notice certain things and
uh for example i've mentioned this
before like i have my uh
you know uh conversations with my tutors
in persian or arabic or whatever
and of course that they'll and then they
send me a report with my errors or
things that i struggle to say so then i
review those
so i i've now noticed that those are
problems but next time i'll make the
same mistake again
and i notice that i'll have my tutor
conversation report
week after week after week the same
mistakes show up so the fact that you
noticed it doesn't mean you're going to
make it
you know you're going to be able to
correct it right away it doesn't work
that way
but but as you notice it again and again
and again
slowly you develop new habits
so i i think that's important and and
often if we speak with people and we
struggle
we know where we struggle and we may
struggle again in the same spot the next
time
we start to become aware that those are
things that we have followed with and
then when we see those
structures uh in our reading or in our
listening we hear those structures and
slowly slowly we start to develop new
habits emphasis on slowly
when it comes to language learning
exactly
um especially you know if you're a
beginner you just have to be okay
with going so much more slowly than than
you're used to
um but you're still gonna get there
faster than if you tried to
you know uh you know just learn through
flash cards or like try to hack
language learning it's right it's really
exactly um so we we tend to get a lot of
um you know similar questions so i i'm
sorry if i'm not getting to everyone's
question guys but i really encourage you
to go back through
some of our previous live streams and of
course um steve's
steve's youtube is just a gold mine for
you know language learning tips
um i have a more specific one here that
i don't know if you're gonna
know the answer to um someone asked
is there any good french science fiction
that you recommend
um i've been on this week of 45 days and
want to make sure i get some interesting
stuff in so
this person's at the halfway point need
something first of all
i do not read science fiction in any
language fair enough
everybody has their own interests but i
would google
or i would go on youtube zero to hero or
whatever it might be
go and find something uh you know i
would go to some of the publishers in
france
where they have ebooks and audio books
and see what you can find
that's what i do my interest is history
so i'll go you know in
whatever language you know polish
history put it in polish
click polish history ebook audiobook
click then i'll find a publisher that
has some of these
and um and that's where you gotta look
for it
it is true that finding
relevant interesting content at your
level
is an enormous task and i know i as a
language learner spend a lot of time
doing that
and one of the things that we want to do
in the new link and we may not
be there on day one is to make it easier
for people
to find stuff that's relevant to them
exactly maybe science fiction there's an
area that's of interest to a lot of
people maybe we got to find some way
that
in different languages we bring science
fiction
you know is it how we tag our library i
don't know what we're going to do but
it is a problem and i spent a lot of
time
uh looking for content uh massaging that
content now i have a software that
will divide uh if i find a movie on
youtube that's an hour and a half long
and i want to break that down into 25
minute
audio files i found a
bit of software that will automatically
break any long
sound file into the length of audio file
that i want
automatically then i can take each one
of those audio files
put it on uh happy scribe and get
transcript and now i've got uh time
stamped lessons in sentence mode for
link
but that's a lot of work doing that it's
just a lot of work
and hopefully we'll find some way maybe
we can mobilize members at link to help
each other i don't know what we're going
to do but
the whole task of helping people find
things of interest to them
at their level in all the different
languages i think that's an important
thing and
i think it's an area where the community
can help other members
and what was the name of this software
that you were just discussing
i think it's called wavepad wavepad
all right i'm just sharing that but but
it is an issue because
link has a limit on the length of uh
audio file that you're allowed to bring
in and
uh it works out to about 25 minutes or
maybe
maybe 30 minutes i can't remember
exactly
uh so let me just look it up here on my
computer
okay great and i'm um a wavepad it is
called wavepad so if if you go to
wavepad
wavepad google for that you'll find that
for those who are interested
awesome thanks steve and then i also i
mean this is a
this is a big topic i think especially
when you're in a less popular language
or you know if i think this is pretty
common if you're from
if you're trying to go from intermediate
to advanced
it's so important to stay engaged with
the material and again there's
there's no right way to study as long as
you're engaging with the content every
day and the best way to do that
is to be interested in the content
itself um
and so i think importing is so important
and sometimes users say i don't know
where to find good content
to import so i made an article that i
shared with you guys here in the chat
and this is on the link
knowledge base and it includes a lot of
tips for how to find
content in your target language so
there's a lot of different ways to
um to do this and we have resources that
we've shared
on our forum as well as a big
spreadsheet
full of different websites and all
different languages and countries where
you can find the content
um and yeah you really have to get
comfortable with kind of like
you know searching in places that you
might not have searched in the past
right so thank you steve also for
sharing the resources that you've been
using
you know it's it's unfortunate that we
simply can't share
things that are under copy right yeah
but we can at least share those sources
so that people can go there
and find them themselves but uh i just
think
going forward you talk about a new
year's resolution
so you know links new year's resolutions
to get 5.0
up but and and
it's a receding deadline but whatever
uh but once you do that i think we want
to really
see how we can mobilize the community to
improve everybody's access to
rich compelling interesting content at
their level
yes see what ideas people have
yes we do have um a lot of stuff planned
for everybody
um in terms of content and the library
and being able to recommend
more content for you guys so we do
appreciate everyone's patience and we
are getting closer
all the time um so
regarding you know everyone else's
questions that we haven't had a chance
to get to
um i'm sorry but i i do want to point
out that you know steve has answered
these in one way or another
um and i guess i would just ask you
steve like um
you know holistically what's what's the
biggest piece of advice you have for
people who are
either trying to get started in their
language
um or you know break away from one level
to the next
level over the course of this next year
like what what should they do
well you know i i think you have to
you have to remain positive so i always
go back to i once
attended this language teachers
conference in san diego
the american council teachers of foreign
languages or something
and there was a woman there who gave a
talk and she was the head of the san
diego
university language department and she
said in language learning there's only
three things
that matter nothing else matters the
attitude of the learner
the time you spend with the language not
reading grammar in english
the time you spend with the language
speaking listening reading whatever
writing
so your attitude the time you spend with
the language and
starting to notice what's happening in
the language because certain things can
just keep on passing
by you have to want to notice that they
pronounce it this way not that way
you know i did my thing on french where
i said it's you know
like it's not deviant like the e is
you got to notice that and and you'll
keep on getting it wrong but if you
notice it again you'll eventually get it
right so those are the three things so
to me the we can control for sure we can
crawl control the first two
the noticing is something that develops
as a result of
the first two so if you if you like what
you're doing
if you think it's worthwhile doing i'm
glad i'm learning this language this is
something i want to be doing
i don't want to be texting with my
friends i want to be
learning the language it's worthwhile i
enjoy doing it
i think i can do it i think the method
that i'm using it might be
link in combination with some other
activities at school or
you know other software that you're
using whatever whatever i'm doing
i believe in it i believe in that what
i'm doing is worthwhile that the way i'm
doing it is
is is is working
uh i like the language i can do it all
those positive things are super super
important so therefore do things you
enjoy doing
because it's very hard to continue doing
stuff that you don't want and doing
enjoy doing just because you think it's
good for you that's not going to work
for very long so you've got to find ways
to enjoy it
so it might be belgian hip-hop
it might be you know whatever it is it
doesn't matter it might be
uh science fiction it might be uh you
know
german rock music or anime or whatever
you got to find things that you enjoy
so that's the positive that's the
attitude side and the second thing is
time
you know it takes time we learn slowly
the brain learns
and this is very important the brain if
given lots of exposure and experience
is going to learn that's what the brain
does it sorts out patterns it cannot do
otherwise than learn it has to learn
if you feed it enough stimulus it will
learn but it learns
slowly so don't be in a hurry to get
you know to fluency because you aren't
going to hurry the fluency
but put in the time that means putting
the time every day
and committing yourself to a reasonable
length of time
you know how quickly can i become fluent
this language well how about you just
start learning the language and see if
you enjoy it
and then keep going and you'll soon find
out how long it's going to take but
there's no
how quickly can i so attitude
time and then after a while if you want
to notice
you will start to notice if you want to
pay attention
to the structures of the language if you
want to pay attention to the sounds of
the language
you will eventually develop these habits
and nowhere in those three did i say
memorization
right master the basics i didn't say
that either
i said attitude time and
ability to notice and uh
yes thank you so much steve and and you
know you also didn't talk about
learning a certain number of words or
you know calculating um a study plan
where you study for exactly this amount
of hours every single day
so that in 90 days or six months you can
do that
if that motivates you you can do that
sure if that is what motivates you i
think that that's an
important uh important modifier too
i just think it's so important that
people aren't um
you know wasting all of their energy
calculating
rather than just getting into it that's
why we have the statistics
at link i always refer to the statistics
i don't know how many people have ever
seen a dog race
when i lived in hong kong you had dog
dresses in macau so you have these
greyhounds
and they chase a mechanical rabbit so
along the side of the track there was
this mechanical rabbit
and of course the dogs are glitches
after the mechanical rabbit
well our statistics are the mechanical
rabbit so
sometimes we need a mechanical rabbit we
need some very specific
specific concrete goal and that's what
those statistics are for
so it helps it's just another it's that
whole characteristic thing
so it's the stick right and and you're
good
and that's all tracked automatically for
you guys too so you don't need to
worry about it too much um and it's it's
so motivating for me to to see
to see my progress and link um
and so couple quick random questions um
someone
says at some point you said you were
going to dive into latin
is that ever going to happen
when did i say that
i have looked at latin i looked at
finnish i looked at
indonesia the other day because we have
them on link
and we have like i don't know how many
there's 35 40 languages i make i would
love to do them all
and at various times i get moderately
motivated
to do this or that but the problem is
there's almost
only so much time in the day and it
takes time to learn a language so
arabic persian and turkish that's a lot
and i'll be on that for a while and when
i'm done with those
done i'm never done but when i feel like
moving on
i might move in the direction of the
sort of uh indian subcontinent so
whether that goes to urdu or hindi or
whatever
lots of punjabi speakers here in
vancouver
but i don't know i know nothing about
those languages there's different
writing systems there so i don't know
but it won't be loud cool um
yeah i saw someone else asking about
hindi too so
yeah of course um it's it's always a
matter of how we're going to spend our
time there's
opportunity cost i know i wanted on
hindi
there are a lot of people who have
translated the many stories and recorded
them in different languages
i understand hindi is ready to go urdu
is ready to go
thai is ready to go some rather obscure
european languages like georgian
i shouldn't say obscure i might offend
some georgians uh it's ready to go
uh tagalog is ready to go so there's a
bunch of languages
that are ready to go but we're not gonna
because it is it's time consuming to set
up these different languages
in the end not that many people end up
studying them so
i push for them mark is not so keen for
obvious reasons
he's gotta you know worry about the big
picture uh
but i i gather that hindi and urdu will
be there but not
until we have link 5.0
uh wrestled to the ground and so it'll
be it'll be a few months yet
thank you steve um and then someone
wants to know are those uh
windows or pictures behind you those are
windows
that's what i thought uh you're in
beautiful uh you're in vancouver right
at your house we're in vancouver yeah
and it's not raining today so it was
raining this morning but it's not
raining now
we've had a very mild winter so that uh
you know my wife and i we've been able
to play golf two three times a week
which is unusual because uh very often
that you know it's
colder and wetter and sometimes we'll
have two weeks of snow and
we haven't had any of that this year hmm
interesting i'm down and it's very green
here it's very green
yeah absolutely it's beautiful it looks
like my home in in portland
i'm still down here in seattle vancouver
is very similar in terms of vegetation
and weather and so forth but vancouver
has more of a
multinational presence um as you said
there are people there that speak
punjabi punjabi like different parts of
the city
but here where i live we have more uh
persian speakers farsi persian speakers
but yeah there's every manner of chinese
punjabis
koreans persian speakers not so many
arabic speakers
i heard a lot of speakers i heard a lot
of cantonese and
spanish when i was up there a couple
years ago
yeah spanish again depends where you are
in the city but i don't hear so much
spanish but there are i mean
certain parts of the city i was in i was
in very touristy places
so maybe that's okay maybe maybe well i
think on commercial drive i think
i think we have had more central europe
central uh
central american people uh moving up
here
great yeah um well i'm down here in
arizona almost almost in mexico myself
so there's lots of space
down here for sure yeah um
steve thank you so much i don't want to
take more of your time um
i i just want to say to all of the the
viewers out there
um call to action go join a 90 day
challenge
and stick to it absolutely and from
there you know
see you know review your stats and and
see where you're at and i think you're
going to be so impressed
with your results and from there you
know the the world is your oyster
go out there and find some content
that's really interesting to you
and start importing it to link and and
make sure you get involved in our
community you know
chat with people on our forum yeah be on
steve's youtube channel
you know look out for more stuff like
this too because we'll we'll keep doing
stuff like this
absolutely language learning is is
exciting
yes it is fun yes okay well thank you
thank you all of you for taking the time
thanks steve it's always a pleasure
thank you shelby
same here all right we'll see you next
time okay thank you bye-bye
bye everyone